foreign
up the night sky along doha's Skyline
the organizers welcome to Qatar give us
a sneak preview of the water and
pyrotechnics show they're putting on for
the World Cup
right now there are empty seats but this
six kilometer strip on the Cornish will
provide entertainment for up to 70 000
fans every day
this show is taking place on a 250 meter
long water Theater now the organizers
tell me it's about two people one from
the East and the other from the West
they're thrown together in a storm where
they must face multiple obstacles
Qatar is proposing itself as being a
platform a welcoming tent or country for
people from all over the world to join
in and regardless of their religion
gender or whatever so and we convey this
message through this this really big
water show that has doubled the scale of
the Bellagio in Las Vegas and has depth
and has drones and a spiral and has cast
and the flames
the final music is called the call to
prayer some calm after the storm
in life you find obstacles and then you
find Wars and nowadays we are all aware
of what's happening but then through the
values of sports we reconciliate we we
get together and we we lived as one
the organizers say this show has a
simple message despite our differences
we're United by the Love of the Game
Laura Khan Al Jazeera at the Cornish in
Doha